Gospel is the most important message in the world.
The gospel is the most important message of the world.
It's more important than global warming.
It's more important than what economy we may
like or not like.
It's more important than what politician we vote for.
All of which has its own sense of importance.
But nothing compares to the gospel for sheer urgency
and importance.
Nothing. Because
your eternal destiny is determined
by what you do with Jesus.
And the gospel is that.
Let's begin with sin.
The fact that we are sinners,
we're alienated from God.
Jesus came to make a sacrifice for sin
that was so complete and so wonderful
that those who believe on him are accepted by god
on his behalf.
And we bring nothing to that table
except our great need.
That's our contribution.
What do you contribute to your salvation?
You contribute your sin.
Thank you very much.
Of which you have a lot more of than you realize.
Alright? And so our contribution is the sin.
Jesus Christ contribution is the redemption
given as a free gift to those who
turn from their sin to him and believe and are saved.